foreign
what's up everybody welcome back to
another amazing episode from the careful
boys where we are currently off the
Record not bad Spirit hey we need to do
that a lot together well it sometimes
sucks when we do it all together yeah
but but that was good that was good it's
the crescendo of the the last part of
the day this time it felt right this one
felt good didn't feel manufactured yeah
yeah yeah well uh today everybody's
familiar with that you know that phrase
you know to walk a day in someone else's
shoes so let's let's think of shoes some
people wear high heels and I don't wear
those okay because I'm not gay just for
the hypotheticals if you were to walk a
day in someone else's shoes who would it
be and why oh that's a good one not a
woman's because I don't want to be
confused for being gay yeah I don't want
people what and it's hard to walk in
high heels you might break your ankle
one one wow and I'm already tall and I
think that being six above six four
looks weird would you be a short guy you
want to be a short guy no no I'm not
sure even a second I have you heard of
the hazda tribe
right now it's making me feel a little
left out no the I don't know the
lighting change and my eyes got hurt it
actually does help my eyes like you're
more alert you look blind
yeah dick actually looks fine I got
these for 12 on Amazon I wanna be
the very best no I want to be in a um I
want to be in a hunter-gather tribe
so walk in the shoes of a
hunter-gatherer yeah and then I wanna I
wanna like you know Avatar nah they're
Barefoot yeah so I want to feel what
it's like to be barefoot and calloused
up for so many years that you can run on
rocks and it doesn't even hurt and then
I also knowing what I know now but then
I can experience their world it's kind
of like Avatar you know how it goes into
that trap they're like you want like a
baby which one like the Dante Bosco
Avatar no okay the blue people Avatar
yeah the Avatar that makes you want to
go on a hunter-gatherer chart I want to
know how different it is
uh
for my life in modern like World
technology comfort in house far away we
strayed from natural distance I want to
feel like waking up
when the light comes up naturally yeah
is there is so like I don't know if like
in this life like
are there things that are um tight
unbalanced in my body am I eating like
am I optimal like not saying like being
a hunter-gatherer you're at the peak of
health and fitness but like you probably
just feel completely different and
you're not with the phone just catching
[__] eating a [__] salmon whatever it
is you think you'd be hungry all the
time I don't know because that's what
you're eating every day and that might
be good for you actually is your porn
just like chopped on like a cave wall
I think my porn have a [__] right like
oh that's pretty good I probably see
your neighbor's wife and you're just
jacking it to her but that's that's cool
yeah yeah but they all have titties out
I probably see a girl's earlobe or
whatever that tribe's horny thing is
like she might have broad ass shoulders
or a long neck or they might just have
like a bunch of like certain like you
know body paints that like symbolize
some sort of prestige that [__] probably
makes me horny how long do you think you
would do it for him you think you want
it for like a day or like a week until I
start missing my life here I guess so
it's convenient yeah
you know what you know what I really
love I would love to see what it's like
to live in a super small nothing town
where everybody's just knows each other
and I would work at a cafe and just see
the same people and everyone's just
really friendly and satisfied with life
like cheers dude that sounds like you
could do that now yeah why why do you
want to do that well I don't think I can
do it now I think you'd have to be there
a long time yeah but why do you want to
do that like what's a draw because I
want to see what all the Hub of is
because people love that and we don't
have that here it's really rare to build
that that's true and it's very opposite
of how we live in this fast-paced like
City so I wonder what it's like for
people that never leave town you know
like it's the same generations of people
in this little like you know spot but
they're completely content I want to
know why like what's that thing do you
think they're content or they're just
defeated
nah I think they're actually
legitimately are cool with it I think
they're fulfilled every day
maybe I don't know if it's changed since
the internet age when they have to be
aware of [__] everything but like I
know that's a it's definitely like a
thing that's why uh Dave Chappelle lives
where he lives yeah he lives in Ohio
super small town and he says everyone
just knows him he knows everyone but no
one's about the Hollywood fame or life
and it's just so refreshing when he has
to do his meetings he flies to La does
his stuff but he goes right back and
there's like no noise he doesn't even
have a cell phone his assistant is the
one that posts things for him he has a
flip phone so he can still talk to
people but he has does not have a modern
phone yeah that's my voice like that for
me that's my my boring answer my cool
answer is I would want to be I would
want to know what it's like to be an
undercover spy it's infiltrating a drug
ring and I'm so high up and I'm at the
border of becoming compromised myself
where they're wondering if I'm ever
gonna Johnny
yeah I did the the [__]
because it's like you you have to make
such a pivotal Choice that's [__]
scariest you can't go back either and
you're starting to get close with the
gang
wait is the American government the bad
guys I don't know I like this guy right
and you're missing all your chickens and
then your station doesn't know where you
are your wife forgets that you're you
know like all that stuff is like slowly
scary and you're about to just fully
commit to this extra life it's kind of
like the Avatar though if you think
about it right because you like the blue
guy the blue you become the blue guy the
shooting one the shitty one yeah did you
see the new one
did you see the new one did you see it
no there's yeah wave the water yeah I
saw that number two is the two better
than one uh I think it's different but I
think it's still fun really entertaining
so my neighbor
says that it's really good but he has
terrible taste so I think probably it's
not good I think it's like if you watch
an IMAX and you like visual spectacles
it's really fun it's genuinely [__]
Titanic and Avatar Avatar wave the water
down I like Titanic then then you're
gonna because there's certain scenes
that are literally like wait this is
James Cameron this is from Titanic but
it's just the blue people inside yeah
because he knows how to do water and
[__] the drama and the music and the
splashes so you liked it I visually
because I was watching IMAX I was in I
was a little high you're high that's it
that's that's that's the key problem
probably helps she gets high it is help
it does help I don't get high yeah any
other movie reviews I think John Wick
for me I would be one of those guys who
is in pornography and gets his dick
sucked every single day but that's not
the best part to me it's trying to
complain about my day to other people
they're trying to be like like I know
that you think this is the type of like
oh my God today is so [__] crazy like
this chick's like
thrown up in my [__] [__] again and
I'm like oh my God the acidity
they're just like completely
flabbergasted they have no idea what to
say and they're all just not relating to
me whatsoever which they're being polite
and you're talking to like a priest a
virgin a guy that's just in cell I've
been married for 40 years and his wife
thinks that blow jobs are disrespectful
yeah yeah that's your boy yeah and
you're just like I don't know what to do
yeah I'm like oh my God I'm so sick of
going to work I go to work again
tomorrow morning early this time it's a
threesome scene with two girls fighting
over my [__]
it's honestly such a great answer though
that's a great answer gotta admit it
sometimes I just feel like a piece of
meat you know what I mean guys you guys
know what I'm talking about all right
hey hey to that huh [__] meet up here
here hey guys I think tomorrow's my last
shoot honest to God I'm sick of this
life
Nick dude I think I would be an NBA
player bro wow you like basketball that
much like I do but then I don't are you
on stilts but the life the life of NBA
life is sick too though the Hoops are
lower than eight year old so no I'm the
guy that I'm the guy that's cleaning up
the the wet spots that's me are you are
you a benchwarmer yeah hey are you a
bench you want to wear Gatorade no he's
like a Mugsy Bogues yeah yeah yeah sure
God again right yeah but I mean like the
lifestyle of an NBA player I just think
it's so cool right having a lot of kids
not even that oh I talk I literally mean
to the point of I going to practice
every day and then just working on like
one skill or whatever like whatever
skill set it is whether it's like free
throws lay up lines whatever just having
like a structured regimented practice
the purpose is pretty consistently yeah
and then and then by in three days you
have a game and then you do that
consistently everything like every
single week I think that's something
about that to me I just feel like is
literally what if we only had one day to
do this one one day it's great one day
in the life one day is great bro A Day
in the Life yeah you know say I'm saying
Michael Jordan and I might change his
answer from being like basketball
practice to like I don't know the NBA
Finals like one game you know what I
mean you might want to throw that game
five making the game-leading shot at the
buzzer if the finals would be the best
that's cool but like like dropping like
being Luka doncic bro you know [__]
like losing game yeah arguing with Kyrie
Irving all the time
I hope that one day you guys win the
game though would you choose practice or
would you choose a game day if it was
only one day I would definitely do I
would do a game day and then like think
of it like Kobe style you know what I
mean like getting shots up four hours
before the game for three you know just
like putting shots up I think something
about that to me I'm like man that's
really cool it is cool as [__] yeah I
mean you could be like Michael Michael
Jordan after the game you keep
practicing you know what I mean yeah man
you're like
some guy in court said like hey Michael
you're the greatest ever and you're like
I will
believe you said this [__] to me
that's it that's only what about in the
past what about Infinity I was uh
reading this book by um Michael's
trainer
and uh he's trained also Kobe too so
he's a legendary trainer and like the
best dudes yeah and he was saying like
those guys at that level they're so
[__] ritualistic because they not
like you know for us we're trying to be
at the a game right they're trying to
bring the a plus plus plus game but
every single time so one of the times I
forgot what it was
um but Michael's just an extremely
competitive guy no matter what so even
when he's like all right I'll meet you
guys at the court he's racing them like
he jumps in a Porsche or his Ferrari and
he's racing his [__] Butler racing
his his haircut person he's racing
everyone because he's everything is a
[__] He's gambling with them yeah
because everything is a [__]
competition right it's like 20 bucks
yeah yeah I forgot what happened but he
ended up being almost late so his
assistant uh I don't know his cult his
uh personal trainer was like oh [__]
well I'll just make it easy on you and
what Michael usually does is every
single game he has a brand new box of
shoes and he laces them up this time he
laced it for him Michael here you go put
these on get on the court he takes them
he throws it away he goes nope I have to
lace it myself like that even to that
detail and he asked him why throw sit
away he asked him why he goes the
feeling that he gets when he opens a
brand new box of shoes teleports him to
when he's a kid and that's what he plays
for he plays for this feeling so if you
[__] with his feeling he doesn't have
this like Primal like I never had shoes
my whole life I finally got my own pair
of shoes I need to have that feeling I'm
like what if Steve green things that's
done it could be done
seriously also getting a safe throw up
on his dick that day and he's like ah I
can't believe he was happening to me
again I was [__] that was cool let's
put it here who would you switch with
for me I think it would have to be
um
maybe with some sort of like musical
Genius Like that's a good one Michael
Jackson Hans Zimmerman he's alive yeah
checks yeah Quincy Jones or someone like
brianma even or like but like to be in
the studio and see someone create a
masterpiece from scratch Timberland it's
cool yeah yeah yeah that's cool yeah
like do you like hear it and then hear
the idea and then like see it like come
together I think that'd be really really
I just saw this interview they asked
Rick Rubin they're like so what do you
do you know uh
they just I don't know they just trust
my sound he always says that he's a
[__] genius too he then plays a [__]
out of himself too yeah he he loves that
did you have one Anthony I I mean I I
had so many thoughts that are going
through my mind I love I love Joe's like
hunter-gatherer stuff too because and I
think about like that that fishing tribe
where they like go deep sea dive yeah to
live on the little boats out there they
hold their breath for like five minutes
right the Filipino group because I do
also like Avatar I do wonder how far are
we away from what we're intended you
know yeah or just even physically
capable on a completely different scale
from anything that I know in my current
Modern Life right so I do love stuff
like that and the thought of that I do
love the idea of maybe even being like a
male porn star Tiger Woods for a day
that's a lot of hot girls yeah yeah it
is but just even the idea of like your
day maybe desensitized to him now but
like if I could just go on like the
illest golf courses on the world play
and it's just like you get to just play
golf at the highest level and people are
just watching you do this luxury
relaxing sport that takes like four
hours you're just getting a [__] ball
of the stick you know but but better
Michael Jordan will play like 36 holes
before he [__] throws down 40 points
in a game later that night so it's like
whoa there's levels to that [__] did you
see the interview of Tiger Woods talking
about how so they said who do you who
would you love to play golf with the
most like if you could just pick people
to play golf with and he said my son
like obviously me and my son and he's
like and all the porn stars I was
[__]
I like the tampon they're really good
with balls
and he's like you need a lot of clothes
I also have no idea how this life would
be but like there's this random thought
the complete other direction of the
hunter gather is like what if we were
just like Saudi princess for a day
that's a good that's actually what I'm
scared of that's a really scared of some
too much pleasure and then you come back
and you're depressed because you can't
have it again yeah and you're like like
Inception when they wake up it would be
almost like playing a video game it's so
far from your world that like you
wouldn't even associate it with what you
know only especially for a day only a
guy who wakes up in the morning and cold
plunges and then works out and then
[__] runs seven miles is like I don't
think I would like Comfort very much you
know it's funny too it would be kind of
cool to be Andy Warhol at the era where
he could have done any piece of [__] and
people go it's genius and they're just
watching you and waiting for you to like
do something everyone goes people Sue
cam but it's a blue label and everyone's
like oh my [__] God the father of
contemporary it'd be pretty funny to
[__] around that whole day and just make
pieces of [__] and everyone just like oh
it's Timeless and I don't think there's
something to say you know to the idea of
like having a curiosity and a desire to
go to like both ends of the spectrum and
there's experience oh yeah yeah to have
absolutely nothing and be completely
content with just like a lifestyle of
like survival yeah just as much as like
to have way more than anybody in the
world ever would possibly need and just
to taste like the idea of being like
um I don't like the look of this entire
building plowed down we'll build another
you know what I mean just like
unnecessary power
um but who knows it's just a curiosity
versus like a desire you know what I
mean one of those uh one of the things
that I see Saudi princes do that I think
is really cool is have you seen them set
up camp in like the middle of the desert
they bust out all these like hookah and
tea and they just have this massive
spread of like grapes and food oh yeah
yeah yeah and then they just chill and
talk with the homies and like that's
great smoking chats chill out yeah yeah
women right I just chill I'm like
but we need to go into the middle of the
desert and just set up those cabs and
then have that spread and I want that
whole thing maybe like six or seven
tigers are just chilling around yeah
when you just want to be entertained
yeah that's crazy but you know what I
mean it's just exotic yeah yeah yeah
yeah and unattainable to like our
normalcy because our version of that is
like you got your cat and then I'll
bring some Pringles over and then make I
mean we could get
it on you know and then like maybe we'll
you know talk and and Munch on some
chips and grapes the other thing I would
do is walk a day in Geo's shoes so that
she can never [__] complain ever
again because all [__] easier like
this'll be how [__] hard that [__] is
oh my man I've been living your life
today she has a period and suddenly this
guy's like I can't do it I can't do it
what is this this is
kind of cool too is to switch places
with somebody that's at the very very
highest clearance of information in the
world oh yeah and to just know
everything they know what if you go back
to your regular life though and like
you're [__] like like I would rather
than naivety and ignorance crazy so
you're basically you have the brain of
Wikipedia or you just yeah or the
alternative Dark Wikipedia or some [__]
like just something there's probably an
ironic twister like dark dark mirror
where like you're you're [__] Julian
Assange and you're in a prison cell you
have all the information I feel like why
did I choose this I had one person I
could switch with and now I'm in a
prison cell knowledge is not exactly
right this is why Pamela Anderson is
coming to visit you now which is a fact
she comes to visit him all the time you
guys know that really like whoa panel is
coming and then she comes and she's 74
years old and you're like [__]
[Music]
yeah and every time he goes [__] yeah
well he doesn't know how old she is now
he's like oh my God 1998 Pamela let's go
and then she comes and then let's go you
know he's like wait what year is it God
God quickly what
what's up 1033
oh my God there's gonna be dust coming
out of that [__] thing
geez but at least I got a visitor
would you guys rather be would you guys
ever want to be uh it's Scottie Pippen's
shoes and feel what it feels like to be
the best second place ever I know that
feels like
in every way and everybody kid is
railing his wife dude that sucks but yes
his wife but that's his wife I mean that
was his wife that's true God man Michael
is like literally dunking all over the
guy and dribbling all around him in
every way Pittman wakes up and it's like
Jordan Jordan
hey David can we do an ESPN spot about
when you were with Jordan but he's also
the best yeah at the being second do you
think he feels like Robin with Batman do
you think he's like he's filled in his
role like that's who I am I think
Scottie Pippen is better than Robin
Batman trained Robin like Scotty's good
on his own yeah Scottie Pippen it's
imagine if Robin could beat all of the
Batman villains by himself
and then there's still Batman but Robin
can't Robin needs Batman that's the
that's the hard thing I would never want
that because I would hate to feel what
it's like to have all of that skill yeah
and all that success and still feel a
shadow like that sucks and worst thing
of all your name is [__] Robin
Pippin all right well yeah is that
Jordan Jordan has a ramp in or would you
rather be call him alone being that good
and never touching the ring just because
you happen to be in the same area no not
Karl Malone
I'd rather be deadly shrimp I'd rather
be home alone what if you're hey what if
you're Chuck
and you gotta wake up every day and
you're rich as [__] but Shaq is gonna
give you hell about high school all
these championships
and no matter what you say to Shaq
because you're a Chuck right Shaq's like
well at least I got all these
championships
he would also be cool to be one of those
school that has one of those extinct
skills yeah you know those lost skills
that some people have like where there's
only one more guy that can make a
perfect sphere there's one more guy that
you know like there's one more dude
I'll take you the whole day you don't
get to do anything else I mean because
when that guy's dead that's it's over
yeah like like you make this cultural
stained glass or like Pottery no one
else does or like yeah use Ancient old
techniques or to be like those shooters
that can volley a rifle shot and hit a
Target like a mile away
Hanzo you're just making one sword the
whole day yeah it's pretty cool man I'll
be John Wick for a day how about that
that's pretty cool that'd be cool he's
not a real guy [__] he run around and
kill people the whole time he'll be
sweating a lot and bleeding a lot but
he's not real I wonder if he wanted to
be himself bringing the rules I want to
know what it's like to feel like the
most peacefullest person in the world
who is that no if you were if you
whoever that person is Judge Judy was
Gandy Scotty Pippen I don't know a
golden retriever
a golden retriever might be oh yeah it
might be honest I'm still alive I'd say
Scotty's pretty peaceful
thank you
[Music]
foreign